hi hi i am fabienne
I am a first year student
creative marketing and innovation
at De Hoogte school Rotterdam
and I'm going to tell you today
why I chose this training
let 's go
well as the very first before I started this training
Uhm I have completed havo
and I was very much looking for 1 broad education
so I soon ended up with commercial economics
and you have at high school Rotterdam
different communities
for the commercial economics training
and then speech creative
marketing and innovation actually appeal to me the most
because I am quite creative myself
and yes creative marketing actually says that itself
you can be creative
and that really attracted me
and also the piece
ehm economic theory and innovative
strategy that you learn in this training
that eh also seemed very interesting to me
the training also appealed to me very much
because it is very practical
uh in the creative training
marketing in ovation you also have the theory subjects
and the theory you learn there
you actually do the same with the practical lessons
and yes it really feels like you are doing useful
and uh I am quite practical myself
so for me it is extra fun
because you are right The Things you learn
can apply
I also really liked it
that the lessons of the training
creative marketing and innovation actually
barely take place in large lecture halls
but just in 1 classroom
where you sit with about 40 and 50 people
ehm it works very well for me
because it feels much more personal
and you can actually answer the questions you have
directly to your eh teacher
and yes that is really great
so are you looking for 1 creative education
where you also learn economic aspects
then creative
marketing and innovation might be your education
so I SAY
come and have a look soon and I'll see you there